alright we're ready for another edition
of a beginner breakdown all right
excellent so we have a position on the
board from the gateway action tournament
gateway is our Scholastic program here
in st. Louis ran by mr. Bower and so
there was a lot of kids over at a slew
of the college and here it is here's a
position from a from one of the games
it's black to move you see any good
moose or black in this position anybody
have any ideas but looking at it for
seven minutes now anybody got any ideas
anybody all right Knight to f1 check
fortunately it looks like they'll play I
got your name where do we have any
follow-up Queen to b6 like g3 all right
he's got one move yeah well actually
look at that he's got two moves oh I got
your coin got your coin that's why I
like Queen to b6 a little bit better
than Queen to g3 all right so let's not
just give away a knight let's let's
think of something better here
so you want you want you want to do this
and then unfortunately we're just
trading pieces and now we're we're down
a piste he's got two bishops and we got
one night he's got to ruck so instead of
checking what if we could thread a check
in this position every kind of cool how
can we thread to not check a discovered
check that is going to d6 yep
okay good good and in the game the
player got so distraught that he just
gave up he's like oh my god there's no
way I can stop what's happening cuz if
you just play like a random move like oh
I'm going to attack your rook what move
does black play to seal the deal it's
checkmate in two moves there we did the
first time right nine f1 he can't go to
g1 because of the other night so he's
got to go here and then we swoop in for
the checkmate he tried to move well
eventually he tried this but it still
doesn't work because he can't take the
Queen because it's double check and then
checkmate
but what would what would you do in this
position if you were white to have some
kind of a defense to this checkmate yeah
you just take the knight right yeah you
drop the exchange but you know you live
to play another day right so all right
so here are some other games from the OL
Gateway action tournament here all right
here we go so some zoo has the white
pieces against today let's see how it
goes all right d4 d5
you all remember Zhong zu from the blitz
bounty in which I went three endo
but it was Martin Zuzu he at that point
but we found out the real truth since
then so takes takes it's the night out
protects the pawn so Bishop d2 not the
most active Bishop you ever saw and
Zhong zu well has the white piece of so
so black is winning even though you know
his pieces aren't doing that much but
they're way more active than whites so
now we have a test he just played Knight
e5 do we want to take this and double
his pawns but that way it attacks the
night you know then he might try like f4
or do we simply want to just you know
develop another piece and put more
pressure on e5 that's what today's
chooses so there it goes long zoo
defends it black gets castled
and now he takes bishop okay so we have
two choices excuse me
we can either take with the Queen which
looks sensible but we got this really
nice battery or we can double our pawns
notice with these double pawns one you
open the B file for your rook Veta would
love that
or and also these double pawns won't be
double very long so let's just double
our pawns and then we can up them in a
moment here so Knight to a4 threatens to
win a pawn nice try takes takes now what
should black play here this is this is
something that when we watched last week
in the Stonewall Greyson kept dropping
his F pawn but nobody took it and here
we go again he doesn't take it
ridiculous and so it defends it
you know if somebody lets you off the
hook you might as well make them pay for
it
so now f6 not to not to good night back
the c3 challenges so it's like okay I'll
trade whatever not a 5 ok so you could
have had a pawn but now you're gonna
trade a pawn for a ponceau pawn takes
pawn takes pawn takes you can't take
because the bishop and the rook defended
it but he gets this cool check-in so he
blocks it so now today piles on and he's
also hitting the beep on notice that if
white will make a random move here right
he doesn't dwell he doesn't want to take
there even though you can't take the
Queen you could take the bishop so he
does not what so the threat is not much
but he just takes anyway and gets
checked again so King to h1 okay so
let's see if black has a cool move here
anybody let's play the most aggressive
move possible that is not a check yeah
rook F 2 and here comes Zang Zoo
thinking small he's like oh my God he's
after my pawn whatever should I do
I better protect it oh well first first
things first all right I give some do a
little credit first things first he he
does actually address the situation all
right but obviously he can do that so
takes takes yep take take take with the
rook and now he's thinking I got to
protect my C pod
so now black should put a hurt on this
kid he he attempts to obviously but
but not as good as he could you have a
forced win in this position where does
this Queen want to be anybody G to write
or H to doesn't matter but yeah it's got
to get to G
alright it really wants to get the G to
the excellent Queen to III because he's
threatening to checks here one Queen to
f3 which is covered by the queen or
queen the deep efore check mate
you can't stop both songs ooh yeah no
matter what you try right
there's just oh man oh now maybe you
could have sings ooh oh but you dropped
your rook so yeah there's no escape but
unfortunately his opponent plays d4
saying you ain't ever gonna stop my
Queen to d5 check followed by mate
little did songs uno coz he walks away
after this move but what move can white
play to live at least another mover to
Queen G 1 ain't gonna cut it
oh oh oh
sad days alright look it's white to move
he doesn't want to get checked on d5
what move can you play c4 right you
might as well right he's like darn I
can't check you I've got to take your
stuff and beat you anyway but at least
you get the play on right let's see what
songs you actually played here looks
like Queen to e1 nice try and game oh ok
so so you got to be resilient alright
you can't just give it up
all right OneNote all right that was
tonight today actually I know had a
great tournament and I believe you want
it so that was good so here's another
game from one of my students
Aristotle so let's see let's see how he
plays he plays his white and he got off
to a really good start two and a half
out of four but then he got worn out
okay
so Aristotle is white okay so his
bishops attack okay let's move it
probably not the best place to move it
but all right because you're you never I
keep telling them you never want to go
and do your opponent's territory without
a specific plan like he can easily get
attacked every which way but you know
his opponent not the best I guess here
he goes again alright so Knight to be
five so now he's like Mike I got two
guys on c7 I'm doing it okay
so obviously his opponents should play
d6 but let's see actually what his
opponent plays here all right he tries
to be a hotshot and play Knight to d5 so
look at how many times this Knight has
already moved in the game one two three
four four out of six moves one night
move and guess what if Aristotle was
smart what would he play here
efore right come on Aristotle but
instead yeah instead he plays III not
far enough
and then yeah great teacher right well
here here is why I am a great teacher I
told them if they even if they even
scrape the piece you yell touch move
even though the kid accidentally touched
his King Aristotle was like touch move
you touched it you're gonna move it yeah
so hey
hey they're old enough to play some
chess okay you all not to play you got
it you got it play all right so King e7
and so Bishop attacks the night so what
do you think blacks next move is
obviously just King back and so Bishop
takes Knight removing the defender of c7
here
can you believe black actually played a
good move here I don't
so d6 yeah you attacks the bishop so you
could be like oh well two of my pieces
are attacked but I can take one of yours
but unfortunate doesn't quite work
because two of your pieces will still be
on pre on pre means under attack by the
way or hanging whatever you want to say
okay so but he should get something for
it I mean you might as well get
something you know but all right he just
retreats and you know all right
he gets his Bishop back so white gets
castled and he's feeling good because
black can't castle so he's pretty happy
so Bishop moves a three tying up the
best move but whatever alright Bishop
attacks the Queen will he see it yes so
he decides the pin is night I'd rather
play Bishop e7 but all right so Knight
back attacks the bishop
Bishop takes Queen takes f6 all right so
Bishop retreats g5 so he's getting a
little attack going but but that's why I
say a lot never play f6 because it
really weakens from your light squares
when your king is either on ei tour even
on g8 right so I mean white can
obviously check here I hope I really
hope he does he doesn't but obviously
you check right why wouldn't you he'll
eventually do it I got faith in them all
right there he goes
so night blocks and notice Queen can't
take the pawn because the other Queen
protects it but you can eat up that pawn
good
so Bishop over protects the pawn just
take it
Queen takes all right so so Aristotle
kind of wants to break it open but by
playing f4 that might not be the way to
do it because he's gonna get a check but
he's like that was a positional
sacrifice because now I got the e-file
open see if it actually works King h1 is
obviously the best because then you're
actually threatening work to e1 all
right but he pins his rook pawn takes so
obviously you can take this because the
knight is in a pin okay but he takes
another guy all right so here's
Aristotle's time to shine get a big
check just keep checking right and
taking stuff all right
so Aristotle is just gonna keep at it
Queen check King up alright so do we
have any ideas for a great move here
I had several and I think the move I
actually really wanted to play did not
work so take a good good look at this
one and see what's up they have Bishop
e5 see that's why they say I'm a
horrible teacher you teach these guys
all wrong things because that's actually
what I would play or actually that's
what I what I analyze the first because
you think wow this is great I'm
threatening checkmate and checkmate
you know you got no hope well it's like
yeah I got a lot of hope buddy it's like
darn it
Lukie 8 all right now you're playing
like air stood oh good job
all right do we have anything better but
along the lines of Bishop to e5
Mia Bishop h6 can we just say game over
it's gotta be all right we're
threatening too much okay
you got nothing you got nothing because
now you can't play 95 because it blocks
blocks the mate and you know yeah just
game over okay all right but he player
what's that game over because that's not
what's played in the game so rookie egg
check was played so check 9 f8 now [ __ ]
up to h6 you could throw in a check but
it doesn't even want to and so yeah you
know what just take take my stuff now
Aristotle misses are made in two here
actually you have two different made in
twos that looks like rook takes or even
Queen takes right but you know Aristotle
you can't he's like you can't get me a
queen I'll take it you know deal and
then I just take all your stuff okay
check you're not gonna like this oh so
no no perpetual check but nice try
and this way you are you always got to
throw and check this to see so the game
ended and then yep
and then yeah it's alright game oh so
here's another game
Aristotle played but not at the
tournament okay not at the tournament
today new had a big crowd watching him
so instead of going for checkmate
he just humiliated his Pete his opponent
all right so let's check it out so
Aristotle was white captures alright big
mistake alright so your night is under
attack
you should just eliminate the pawn right
instead he plays I'm gonna attack your
queen right but you have one piece on
three and so with f3 now you have two
pieces on pre so you're gonna lose one
so he said all right I mean at least
gonna get a pawn for it all right
Queen takes attacks the Bishop Bishop
retreats Bishop attacks the Knight
Bishop takes pawn so oh yeah he takes
takes Queen to e3 now what other check
do we have besides III that just makes
the computer go wild like he's so
excited about this move he's not crazy
about hate for ya
Bishop to b5 Shak and now I blocked you
yes like I'll take you and you're like
oh my god and then it's like Shaq yeah
now I got a queen and you want to
promote to a queen all right that's good
all right and now you got your queen
back and you're doing great all right
but Aristotle you know that's that's a
little tough so Queen to III check
Bishop blocks now Bishop to b5 check c6
takes Queen to a5 really doesn't get the
job done right
because now we got the same thing pawn
takes check King over let's get
ourselves another Queen obviously uh
upside down pawn services and King not
in our tournament game but but in a fun
game and let's see how many mates this
guy can miss alright so so first things
first he takes the rook and what else
should we take with Czech Bishop let's
see let's see if we can get mate here
there's a king you and have him move all
right he's got one lousy move all right
Queen to c6 is mate can't wait can we
shout out like all the mates Knight to
d5 is not a checkmate cuz you removed
the defender of the bishop how about how
about that please that's why that's why
we gotta use this computer because it
says when it's mate and that might be
and this this looks pretty pretty like
mate alright so he misses three
different mates all for a precious rook
okay yeah I miss teacher okay so alright
I'll take all the Christmas is really a
criticism on me coming there but you
know sometimes it's more fun just to
humiliate people than to checkmate right
so check always yeah always and now the
kids feeling good cuz hey I got your
bishop alright well good job okay good
job okay you got checked all right he
knows not to move into the corner that
was smart
all right so he's making a run for it
check and another check
so close to mate Oh check check
got your [ __ ] up hey Bishop and now
he's like yep I got all your pieces just
just give up well well unfortunately
this is not a stalemate cuz he kept
pawns the move but he doesn't want to
play this a five or else there will be
checkmate all right but you have no you
missed a lot of mates and but you know
he had a lot of fun that day huh all
right so let's see another position from
this gateway action tournament so so
Jonathan are Gullah party was playing
black he was one of the favorites going
into this tournament first round playing
one of my former students
Jonathan Lake he he likes to just bang
the pieces and play really fast okay
that was there was the extent of our
lessons okay just play really fast and
and get him okay notice white is down
you can no regard for pots no return no
it's like I hate pawns and my work who
needs that who needs a rook on 81 you
know okay so so he's playing fast and
Jonathan at this points probably just
thinking you know it's round one this
guy jump jump jump so so white bangs out
oh well not not a four he banks about
her as as requested before hey four he
bangs out Knight f5 it's good to move
our pieces and make attacks rather than
just Saipan alright so and Jonathan's
like you are but there's another point
all right so so you guys see it I guess
everybody sees it by that reaction
checkmate and that's how one of the best
kids in the tournament goes down not my
student by the way all right
so I saw all these guys having so much
fun at the tournament I was like I'm
taking on I'm taking on anybody all
right so so I'm gonna take on aristeros
dad so if you think aristotle isn't the
best just wait till you meet his dad
yeah all right so I had the black pieces
all right so II 4 C 5 D 3 9 up and now
he makes the first blunder of the game
okay
here what a guest now we decide oh I
meant to make move my pawn twice well
it's a little late for that because I've
got two defenders so I take so C 3 so
this kind of is a variation of the
Sicilian called the Smith more gambit
but obviously I have an extra tempo but
honestly I don't really like my knight
on c6 here so so notice that even though
I'm playing a player that's you know way
below my level as we'll see you know I
don't need to go going for like a little
attack right away like Knight to be for
Knight up I'm just gonna get my pieces
off the back row and just develop
normally okay I'm not trying to be a
superhero or anything yeah the most fun
you can have in chess is when you win so
it doesn't matter how you get there as
long as you're win the humiliation
everything like that it means nothing if
you don't get the W right or the V or
whatever you call it
all right so Queen c7 he was attacking
my paunch way so I'll take it
and notice Queen attacks the bishop so
sometimes as I say it's better be lucky
than good he plays the moon Queen e2
protecting his bishop I was like wow
this guy might not be that bad
but but I knew I knew all right so so
now I get double double the attackers on
the C file so e5 you know everybody
wants to just attack attack attack right
so so first you should be castled and
have all your pieces in play because
this e 5 is just gonna lose knight takes
now I got two attackers on here and
there's just no escape and now I could
just take it take it take it and easy
easy easy
so he decides to make his king of
warrior which I don't really blame him
but he's got to get off of this efile so
b5 play a little hope just hoping I can
play b4 and and then win rook attacks
the bishop so this guy played in his
first tournament a couple of weeks ago
when the Friday action quads and his
opponent dr. Morris doubled up on the D
file and checkmate him so he's like you
know it worked for that guy against me
it's gonna work here so not a bad idea
actually
b4 so he really doesn't care about his
neck he just wants to check make me on
d8 which really isn't even checkmate but
all right we'll let him have his little
pipe dream okay here we go all right so
he's attacking my bishop but I'm I don't
care I'm attacking your bishop check and
now I'm like all your little hopes all
your little dreams they're done okay
you're done so what move do I make to
just make him like ol me and it was
gonna chick meet you it's like nope you
never were never will what move do I
play here
yeah yeah I love it
B 5 B 5 right this would be Bishop to b4
and then he'd be like really happy yeah
Mississippi 5 so I pin the rook to the
king and then he moves and there's like
if I take your rook or if I take your
Bishop you go back where checkmate me
but nothing I can really do so all right
so so when you know there's a bad move
on the board just don't play it all
right all right so now I played one of
my other students today who actually
scored 4 and 2 and is our best bet
okay so I hope you're not cheering for
my school this year in the state just
championship but you know you never know
here's our hope so let's see how she
plays all right d4 solid c5 she protects
it I take so she gets her Bishop out get
my night out
she gets her night out Bishop pins the
night she breaks the pin it's a II 6 she
gets Castle so so so far so good for for
Chloe
you know she's got three of her pieces
out she's only moved each of them once
and got Castle excellent so I keep
developing and here's where she goes Ron
what would be a better move for white in
this position than to play Bishop to e5
develop the knight right like why don't
you want your night to play there there
you know even if you want to move your
Bishop pin the night by playing there
you you let me take but I'm not going to
take or you can just let me you know
develop a bishop Queen takes so now she
plays the move that
that makes me think she might have a
little bit of Hope here so so black has
a threat in this position if you play
the genius a four here
what what move would black play to get
an advantage it is a tactic
so I have two pieces attacking something
correct yes okay good
okay yeah so we're in agreement I have
to the two pieces attacking something
and that something is the deep on the
deep on is currently protected by a
knight and a queen
if only I could remove one of those by
taking it free point okay and you're
like open oh well it's a big deal it's a
big deal okay so so miraculously she
sees see three good and so I can't
resist seeing if she is any type of
player so so I threatened Chuck mate I
would never play that in a real game
this is this was not even rated but I
just wanted to see if she could see
simple checkmates and she does so that's
good so I get castle Queen up once again
you know why don't you get your night
doing something but all right so Queen
up the computer somehow really likes
this move well I guess I guess maybe she
wants to go to b5 so I play a six hey
whatever so see for not a fan so if I'm
not a fan of it what do you think I do
because I forget do you think I want to
take it no the answer is yes because the
queen is now under attack and they got
an isolated pawn so so here here you go
can you play better than me in this
position because I totally miss it
and keep in mind this is why you got to
develop all your pieces get the rooks
connected this Knight is just sitting
there on b1 you know making this rook
totally totally useless like I want to
play the game
it's like nope night to be four or you
want to play Knight to e5 so Knight to
be four is the move no I don't see it so
now when the Queen moves
yeah yeah yeah right
got your stuff okay so all right but I'm
like yeah I got I got I got better
things to do I want to get my won't get
my rook on the same file is the Queen
the pawn and and do a lot of fun stuff
so obviously you got to just jump your
knight up here alright so d5 and now I
got a lot of tricks so my first trick is
double attack the Queen and Bishop so
Queen moves so check take and now pawn
takes now I got a passed pawn and then
when she takes it's pretty much bad news
take what with the bishop ton ya take
pawn and I'm threatening checkmate and
the Queen
so unfortunately Chloe kind of messes up
here you know it's tough for kids to
concentrate for you know 16 17 moves
what move should Chloe make here to give
her some kind of hope the Queen Queen
jutsu I mean I mean you're still doing
really bad but at least you're playing
the game
she obviously takes my bishop I take but
I even I even said hey Chloe why don't
you just give up you know yeah you got
no hope yeah well I never let him take
it move back but no she's like a key
plane and so she plays worked to e1
hoping that I play rook to c2
threatening checkmate because then what
would she play to end the game and
humiliate me yeah so so you never really
want to give up and especially when
backward checkmate is still in play so
obviously I don't play that
I played g5 and and the game just gets
ugly from there take take now can you
play as good as me here oh yeah we got
made into so don't don't don't talk
until you know you got made into yeah
yeah that's hot
so the answer is not a five give you
that one
or even pawn takes h4 he's out all right
we got one out we got made into Queen to
b6 check does not get the job done cover
the cover the cover the board I'll tell
you I'm not gonna I'm not gonna take my
hand off the piece cuz because he does
not have to go to f1 right he can go to
h1 not good enough
and I want made into hey I'm a guy I'm
busy man okay
impossible
Queen to see 6z6 you're getting better
now I'm not gonna go there I go well
yeah well tack your rook it's still mate
there
all right good job made into good just
for funny play day for okay game over
alright alright here it is and then you
know it's a lot of fun fun playing uh
playing some chests and again some good
results so hopefully my team will do
good at the state just championship all
right good night everybody